[Musique]
yahia sol et cyril salut tout le monde
ok oui consensus
comme tous les matins il croisa cette
même fille avec sans doute afin qu'elle
vienne lui parler
ils espèrent tous les jours ce qu'il
ressent au fond de lui c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'amour mais lui il est timide
et elle est si belle
il ne veut pas y aller il est collé au
fond de son siège une fois lui a souri
quand elle est descendue et depuis ce
jour là il ne l'a jamais revu à y redire
il aurait dû faire crois moi on a tout
dire c'est dommage
ah c'est dommage c'était yasmina une
belle voix elle sait qu'elle est douée
la tempête de sa vie la musique et sa
bouée
face à ces mélodies le monde est à ses
pieds mais son père lui répéter
trouveront un vrai métier
parfois elle s'imagine sous la lumière
des projecteurs sur la scène à recevoir
les compliments et les gets fait yasmine
et rouillée coincé dans la routine ça
lui arrive de chanter quand elle
travaille adesina elle aurait dû
elle aurait dû le faire
crois moi qu'on a tous dit à ces
dommages assez dommage c'est peut-être
la dernière fois il aurait dû y aller
l aurais tu le fais
crois moi on a tous dire c'est dommage
assez d'eau
c'est être là
à voir diego est affalé au fond du
canapé il engueule son petit frère quand
il passe devant la télé ses amis sont
sortis ne les a pas suivis comme ceux
dont seule la lune viendra lui tenir
compagnie diego est triste il ne veut
rien faire de sa nuit dire que les
primes n'aime pas trouvé la femme de sa
vie reprendre diego souffre tellement
tromper ses pairs cette soirée que tu
allais l'avancé il aurait duré trois
mois
on a tous dia c'est dommage ah c'est
dommage c'est peut-être la dernière fois
pauline elle est discrète elle oublie
qu'elle est belle elle a surtout le
corps des tâches de la couleur du ciel
son mari rande bientôt elle veut même
pas y penser quand il y prend le bras
c'est pas pour la faire danser
elle repense à la mairie cette décision
qu'elle a prise à cet après midi où elle
avait fait sa valise
elle avait un avenir un fils a élevé
après la dernière danse
elle s'est pas relevée à l'orée du
allait elle aurait dû le faire
crois moi on a tous dit assez dommage ça
c'est dommage c'est être la der
hier fois on a tous dit assez dommage à
ces dommages assez dommage à ces
dommages assez dommage à ces dommages
assez dommage il aurait dû y aller
l aurais tu le fais
croit on a tout dit c'est dommage ça
c'est dommage
c'était de la neige
alors fois à
réduit à l'est elle aurait dû le faire
on a tout dire c'est dommage
toutes ces têtes
vivre avec des romans avec des brevets
avec les merlus vivre avec des remorques
avec des revenus on est libre avec des
morts c'est ça le secret
[Applaudissements]
ceux qui ont les actions laroche et
l'album la vraie vie c'est un carton
sécurité et les cherry et ben ils voient
les bras ils vont ils vont ils vont
aller ils vont venir ils seront avec
nous toute la deuxième partie d'émission